[Fred Margulies] I attended a, uh, Jewish
school—Adass Yisroel in Berlin,
as did my sister.
Most of the time we were very aware of the
fact that we live in dangerous times.
On Kol Nidre before we went to synagogue,
it's the custom for father to bless his children.
And I remember all the years that I can think
back that when my father blessed my sister
and me,
he always cried.
And I assumed that
it was
because they knew.
Small as you were, you—you realized that.
And, of course, we were confronted daily,
daily,
with a swastika
and the hordes,
and, in the glass cases on the street corners,
the display of the Stürmer.
My father would sometimes pick one up in a
train and bring it home.
So there was this feeling of
an impending doom.
He was taken away very early in the morning.
My mother was crying, and there was such to-do
that my sister and I woke up, and we went
to see what was going on.
And, uh, I remember the policeman saying,
as far as he knows,
that they're being deported to Poland.
And, um, that's the last time I saw my father.
When Kristallnacht came, it was a—a disaster.
And it became clear that life for Jews in
Germany
was... all over.
Decisions had to be made as to who should
go and who should not go.
For example, one of my uncles and aunt
decided not to send both of their children.
They would send one child to test the waters
and keep one child with them
to see if this would work, because there was
no certainty.
It was actually fraught with danger.
And we were made aware of the fact that we
will be carrying a luggage tag on our lapel,
and all it would say is the name and the district
in Berlin which we lived—
no street, nothing else, no identity.
And that we were to act as though we didn't
know from where we came.
We left in the morning, early in the morning.
It was timed so that we would get to the border
at night, because we needed the cover of darkness,
of course.
I remember leaving from Bahnhof Zoo,
and I remember that not—
about a minute or two out of Bahnhof Zoo,
on the elevated tracks of the railroad,
came into view the hull
of this burned and destroyed
famous synagogue of Berlin, Fasanenstrasse.
And that was the last
stab in the heart for a little Jewish boy,
to see the burnt hulk of this famous synagogue.
I also remember very well that my mother took
me into a corner in this railroad compartment,
I remember well what she said to me,
in order to make sure I understood, because,
of course, I was a little boy very attached
to my mother.
It was a great love relationship.
In that little speech in the train,
I always say I became bar mitzvah.
I have not been formally bar mitzvahed.
When I was 13, I was not bar mitzvahed.
I was bar mitzvahed when I was 11.
By my mother. No minyan, no rabbi.
I was given my—my orders, my commandments
as to what to do.
And I remember that.
I was to be the hero of the family—
tapfer zu sein—to be courageous.
And so the journey took—took its last hour
or two.
At the station, as we got off the train, uh,
my mother said to me, you must not try—
you must—must not turn around and look back,
and you must not cry.
And she did not kiss me good luck—goodbye,
because there was just no time.
We went to the left, we children.
And I remember my mother and the other lady
turned to the right.
And that was the last we saw of them.
That was December the 6th, 1938,
in the middle of the night.
I remember having to go to a photographer
in Hoogeveen to have pictures taken.
I still have those pictures in the little
Dutch folder at home.
And, uh, we got to England.
And that was, of course, the last I saw of
my sister, who unfortunately perished in Bergen-Belsen.